[Music]
which one you want longbow
[Music]
i mean the thing comes to january is
very relaxed we have a nice atmosphere
we know each other for a long time i
mean i'm doing tiny camps for eight
years eight years with peter and magnus
so we know each other very well we
always do a lot of sports which is good
for him because he gets into shape it's
also good for me because i get into
shape as well
as a russian i can say like comparing to
russian camps it's yeah yeah i have
worked in a different team before it was
let's put it like that tougher but
i think it goes along that we're trying
to build team spirit also trying to get
some input from from magnus we are
mainly trying to make the opening phase
not important in a way rather than sort
of try to to dominate i think that would
be the russian style or the one i worked
for before but to try yeah yeah so yeah
i think it's exactly his opposition well
here you're up against someone who's
probably also spent half a year together
with a team so i mean the strategy
becomes a bit more and has done it says
that most of the things will never be
seen i mean
well i think i worked for another guy
before magnus and we had like a free
three-month
training camp that basically was useless
in the sense that well our opponent came
with some surprising ideas we hadn't
seen and then basically we could throw
it all not throw it out because it was
extremely useful later but for the match
it had absolutely no relevance and i
think we're expecting similar things
here so we are trying to
well we're trying to cover everything no
honestly
i think i will never see this position
again like especially in the match when
it comes to world championship match
it's like really high stakes and then
you start being paranoid and then you
can
spend some
like really lots of time for
checking something completely insane
[Music]
when it comes to the memory part for
magnus
when it's his time to see all your worth
and start memorizing how does that
actually work no but first of all he has
a brilliant memory actually i mean it's
literally unbelievable in my opinion
like it's quite often that let's say
like
you work on something for like few days
then you
show him once then three days later we
have a conversation and i don't remember
what the move is but he does
and it's like yeah i mean it's obviously
a very decent start for uh for a chess
player to to have such a memory
i think i'm holding
do you want to draw me there
this game will not go good for me
no i wouldn't think so
so playing these games is that part of
how you remember all the work that is
done
well i mean it
helps you uh
helps you understand the position of it
positions a bit better there are
summaries of the work
that i
look at so i try to remember it try to
understand it and
eventually i played in the games
so anything new today something i should
know our nose is something like this
textex castle we say short
small advantage you believe in this for
life
i mean it's just a berlin with uh with a
knight instead of a bishop
what's not to like
okay so let's say bishop c4
yeah but what's your idea i mean so keem
g3
knight d4 actually
white white white
king h3
kimchi six yeah king g4
yeah
yeah i think it's the draw
you